for more on what the tax reform bill
means to you we are joined by Ed O'Keefe
he is a congressional reporter for The
Washington Post and a CBS News
contributor is in our Washington bureau
Edie end-of-the-year high stakes let's
talk about this tax reform bill we've
talked about senators corker and Rubio
do we know if Senator Collins or flake
are in any way on the fence about this
or is this gonna become law they're
still holding out but you know if
history is any guide they'll they'll
waver through the weekend so that we
talk about them a little bit and then
suddenly they'll vote for it in the end
look all of them all of these sort of
last-minute undecideds have had various
things that they wanted to make sure got
in the bill senators have the right to
do that and use their clout and they've
done that and you've saw changes at the
last minute to the child tax credit some
assurances about health care in the case
of flake he's pushing to make sure that
Congress is working on some kind of
bipartisan deal to shore up the status
of those dreamers those young immigrants
it's a big concern of his has been for
years all of this likely will eventually
lead to all of the Republicans it looks
like voting for this and sending around
to the president who are the biggest
winners in this plan ad certainly
corporations Anthony the the corporate
rate coming down to 21% is a very big
deal on the fact that that is permanent
now Republicans say and certainly a lot
of those that are pushing for this lower
rate say will allow for better planning
and they say will spur economic growth
across the country critics of course are
concerned about that they also point out
as Errol did that the individual rates
are not permanent and will have to come
up again for a vote or expire by 2025 so
you know certainly it is being cast as
something that's favorable to the
wealthiest in this country and the
corporations and on paper that's
certainly true and senator Rubio got
what he wanted in terms of the child tax
credit will Senator Collins get what she
wants as far as securing the fate of the
health insurance markets well as of
right now she has no written assurance
and and there's no scheduled vote on the
legislation that would do what she wants
so she is taking a bit of a gamble here
health care remains a big concern in her
state given its aging population and
just given the fact that she heard
throughout this year from constituents
who don't want the current health care
system really to be changed in any
dramatic way
I don't think they would string along
Susan Collins and then not make good on
their promise the question is at what
point and how when Congress consider
this next year and this this tax bill
which is also sort of a health care bill
in a way will remove the Obamacare
mandate starting in 2019 now that the
CBO the Congressional Budget Office says
you know that could lead to higher
premiums and and that as many as 13
million Americans will become uninsured
is there a potential price to pay for
that in this legislation for Republicans
absolutely Democrats have already made a
point that you know this is this is now
putting out 13 million people the
Republican argument is that the tax for
not having health care or the penalty
for not having health care is in fact a
tax so that by removing it you are in
essence reforming the tax system and and
lowering the burden on folks they also
say they argue that a lot of the people
who have been penalised by this law are
actually lower income individuals who
cannot afford health care plans under
the current system and so that's why
they want to keep pushing for reforms to
make individual health care plans more
affordable but you're right the argument
is that tens of millions of people now
are out of health insurance it will be a
campaign issue next year for sure
Democrats already making hay out of it
and they will continue to do so for sure
and what happens to people in blue
states who rely on the state and local
tax deductions it's an interesting
element of this Alex if you live right
there in New York across the river new
jersey up in connecticut out in
california illinois Maryland
those are higher tax states and they've
been accustomed to being able to deduct
your state and local taxes at this point
it'll be capped at ten thousand dollars
that is a notable deduction still but in
some cases you're gonna have people now
ending up paying higher taxes because
they live in those states and their
local and state property taxes can't be
deducted as much as they were before
that was part of the reason why we are
likely to see at least a handful of
House Republicans from those states
mostly suburban swing districts probably
vote against this plan next week because
they still believe it's unfair to their
constituents all right ed O'Keefe in
Washington this morning ed thanks very
much for being with us
take care